what is up everybody welcome back to
Elemental Gardens today is already the
final episode of this very short series
and today I'll be working on at the sort
of air slash wind elemental parts of the
park and also the fire part which is
going to get ridiculous but we'll get
into that later first I wanted to finish
the sort of air point and I figured the
one ride that is best to place over here
is the forty coaster which I made during
planet coaster college about the forty
coaster it was originally kind of
figuring can I go for an invert or a
flying coaster instead but I think the
4d coaster is at once a very interesting
ride that sort of already has that very
flying feel to it as it's also the only
roller coaster that I had a finished
blueprint of that I could put in the
park and kind of show off that way I
also think it's a really interesting
coaster and definitely one of the more
interesting courses in the game so it
definitely good to show off in that
sense now to kind of create the backdrop
to fit with the theme I took some
inspiration from the movie up actually
Paradise Falls which is the place where
the house sits and has this very large
winding sort of table mountain talk that
ends with one rook sticking out and I
thought that was a sort of way to build
up a scenery backdrop for this coaster
that is at once a nice scenery backdrop
that kind of fits the theme but on the
other hand also a good way to have some
actual scenery interaction from the 4d
coaster because when these things are
built in real life they're usually just
built on a flat plane they're very
compact and it's almost impossible to
really theme these coasters so I think
having a sort of very narrow tabletop
ish Mountain it's something that kind of
fits the theme while at the same time
being one of the rare things that you
can actually have scenery interact with
when it comes to a 4d coaster which has
a very very small footprint and it's
very compact
it's also kind of interesting it's it's
a bit like those Venezuelan mountains
which is inspired by as well I'm pretty
sure that Paradise Falls from up is
inspired by Angel Falls the waterfall in
Venezuela which happens to be the
highest waterfall in the world and it's
really these these mountains which are
very flat on top but have extremely like
large and steep cliffs on the sides with
all these huge caves and everything and
I think it does get the idea of
something that is very much like very
focused on the sky I guess something
that really rises up without you know
going for floating islands which is
something which I didn't want to do in
this case Center which is break the
immersion of the park and make one is so
far somewhat realistic Park into
something that isn't really realistic at
all so I figured this was the best way
to keep the entire park within that
theme and also show off some of the
terraforming in the game because
obviously this is a pretty interesting
way to use the terraforming tools which
I haven't really done in this point yet
and it kind of just shows of how you can
make some mountains so I'm just pretty
happy with how that overall so now even
if it is very simple and this is really
all there is to the backdrop of the
coaster the rest of the queue and the
station will just have a sort of generic
sort of form fitting and idea fitting
station but not really themed in any
sense and since the rest isn't so much
themed I think having the backdrop of
the rock works quite well it also still
does fit the sort of foliage style I
have in this park since in the end I did
choose to go with the tropical biome I
don't have too many palm trees since
that's something I generally want to
avoid unless you're building a jungle
but realistically you don't really see
any theme parks especially of this kind
of skill in the kind of climate where
you can see a lot of palm trees so
instead I kind of want to go for
something that's a bit more like it
could be somewhere in Middle America or
perhaps
somewhere in a Mediterranean ish area
which isn't as arid and some of the
coast of Morocco and Spain are basically
any place that is more subtropical and
actually tropical and I guess in terms
of the foliage style having this kind of
rock fits in as well because it does get
accentuated with a few palm trees in
there and it still has that very lush
very bright sort of sand texture which I
really love about the other tropical
biome when it comes to the textures it's
one of my favorites
but at the same time it's not too
tropical like it doesn't turn into a
rainforest which is a very common sort
of trap whenever people build tropical
parks is that you end up with parks that
are filled with palm trees absolutely
everywhere but especially in a theme
park and especially in many climates
that's just something you wouldn't
really see and even if you do many palm
trees will often require quite a lot of
maintenance so they're not too often of
the sides of any theme park anyway I
wanted to get into the station and again
since all of the stations so far has
been sort of uniquely themed to fit the
theme that they're in so I wanted to
come up with something new here and I
figured one way to get a station done
quickly and with not too many pieces
would be to get a very modern style that
also kind of emulates sort of flying
waving style to it and what I figured
would work in the end was just a waving
blue roof now I didn't want to take the
in game like curved roof since there is
one blue color that you get with the
roof but you can actually change the
color of the roof and that makes it
quite difficult since the shade of blue
didn't really fit the overall feeling of
this coaster I felt and also I didn't
want to use any pieces that you cannot
recolor because every time you see them
in any park that anybody's ever made
they always have the exact same color
and I think that's kind of uncanny I
wanted to go for something a bit more
unique here so I made the roof out of
the sort of roof edge pieces those Ridge
pieces where
think you're supposed to put them
besides roofs but in this case they make
up the entire roof and while that does
give this building a lot of different
pieces it's not the greatest thing for
the performance of the park it does mean
that we get an interesting color and
also a very interesting sort of metallic
texture to the roof as well so I'm quite
happy with how that turned out and it's
not so hard to do it either you can
actually keep the roof on the grid as
long as you first place one of those
very small roof tile tops I don't
actually know what the name of that
piece is exactly hold on I'm actually
check-in the game on the name of that
pieces because there's one roof piece in
the roof trim section here we go it's
called the square roof tile Ridge one
meter and when you place that in any
building you get a 1 meter grid instead
of the standard 4 meters or if you make
the grid smaller 2 meters and especially
in cases like this it can be super handy
to have an extra small grid so that's a
place that's an item that you just have
the place inside a building and you
instantly get a very small grid so you
add this over all very handy little
piece then I decided to make some misuse
of in this case so that's that for the
station and now I wanted to move into
this side of the central piece of the
park and we sort of again emulate what
the landscape looks like on this part of
the park I made a very small sort of
table mountain here with a little bit of
detailing on it a little bit of
texturing to make it really emulate the
look of the larger one while at the same
time hopefully still keeping it in the
sort of scale that the rest of this part
of the park has and at the rest of the
little themed quarter circles have so we
have the small ponds we have this small
little pits going down then we have the
small table mountain here and now we get
into the fire point which is absolutely
stupid this is this is so weird this is
basically the fourth element and it's
going to be fired I mean what else can I
put in there the thing is just it's the
one element that you don't really have
with the
in game terraforming tools so I figured
yeah what's the only other thing that I
can add flamethrowers so that's that's
all we really have there's more of an
idea behind it though
because I of course wanted to show off
some of the things that you can do in
the game and what I haven't really shown
up yet on the trigger effect so that's
something I wanted to put on these poles
over here in hindsight I could have
actually triggered some of these
flamethrowers over here with some
courses as well that's something I
didn't end up doing but in the rest of
this part I will be making a very fiery
coaster and put some flamethrowers on
that because that's just pretty epic and
that's that's really the theme of this
area it's super stupid but it was the
only way that I could actually like
finish off the theme of the park that I
have so far while at the same time
showing off another aspect of the game
which I haven't been able to show off
yet so for the coaster of this area I
chose to take the planet coaster College
coaster on the premier launch coaster
which is pretty much full throttle I do
have to say this is different than your
Bo full throttle since it enters the
loop in a different direction that's the
only thing that is different like the
loop is the other way around
that aside it's pretty much just a
recreation of the layouts so it's pretty
lazy in that sense but it's it's a
little bit different
I wouldn't call an entire like entirely
correct recreation because of that
reason if you really want to recreate
full throttle you're going to have to
actually build the loop like backwards
because you can only build a loop in one
direction on this coaster in-game and
that is a different direction than the
fourth roller was going so that's kind
of interesting but I think it's as it
goes to that bits because if there was
any coaster at all that I would give a
ridiculous over-the-top stupid theme
that completely doesn't fit it's for
Thermo because it kind of has that in
real life
I actually remember I got some weird
comments that when I uploaded this
coaster on the workshop because it is on
the workshop as the planet coaster
college coaster and when I uploaded it I
call it Yolo
and I've got some comments about that
reason is that full throttle for some
reason was marketed using the word Yolo
which is so old like it's it's it feels
very hey fellow kids how are you doing
kind of uncanny it's really stupid but
it worked I guess because it's a pretty
popular coaster and it's very well known
now within the coastal community for
just being that roller coaster that was
marketed piccalo has with people like
just still I believe liking to scream
Yolo on the coaster and that's kind of
why I put that as a name and that is
also why I figured if there's one
coaster that I'm going to be stupid with
and put flamethrowers on the side of
then it's going to have to be full
throttle like nothing else is going to
quite fit that so it's overblown
ridiculousness so this is going to be
ending up a coaster with three launches
we have the first launch into the loop
then we get into a backward launch which
goes up from the heart loop and then
after you go back to that backwards
launch and you have a forward launch
into the toe pads going over the loop
here and finally into the brakes I did
make one other change that full throttle
doesn't have which I believe makes this
coaster better than fourth row which is
that full throttle actually gets
breakdown during the hill at the end of
the coaster so just as you think you're
going to have to have an epic drop at
the end of the coaster it's actually
going to break you right as you're going
down the drop which is mmm I mean I get
why they did it they have some space
constraints over there but it's it's
just a massive I guess anticlimax since
there is this really huge drop and the
drop at the end of all too low is
positively pretty big but you're just
being like slowed down the entire way
down and that's this carnage is quite a
shame so I decided to put the brake run
at the end of the hill here which does
make it longer than
life but hopefully that should make the
final drop a bit more interesting so
that's one more change now as decoration
around the roller coaster here I chose
to put some flat rides around it which
should make it a little bit more fancy
and actually make it feel like it's a
bit more part of the park and that aside
there are just lots of trees to make
sure that this isn't just a park in the
middle of an entire empty Crossland and
we actually have some tree lines to keep
you from seeing that impede Rosslyn and
finally it's about time for the station
of the coaster itself now again I wanted
to have some kind of new style but much
like the other stations this is again a
very modern station but also much like
the other stations I wanted to work a
bit with the color here so I'm going to
choose a color which is pretty much the
same as the color of the coaster itself
in the very near future just go with
some orange metal ish textures and hold
them up with some of those maroon like
frameworks as I did with the station of
the mine train coaster and this is
actually also inspired by the simple
roller coaster green 3 custom scene
resets back in the day it's it's very
simple to build but it looks quite clean
and it really fits the modern style of
the coaster so I figured why not and
just put any modern sort of station in
there that way very simple again and
especially since it's a very small
station it doesn't really stick out too
much but hopefully it works and I guess
a very final thing as an addition to
this coaster are these long-awaited
flamethrowers and these are going to be
triggered so that when you're going to
be launched you can actually see the
flamethrowers being like shooting out
the fire as you're going through the
launch which is ridiculous and maybe not
even that healthy but hey it's something
that you can do in the game so - wanna
try it I'm also not too sure about how
close some of the trees are to some of
those flamethrowers I try to put this
the three hours I
the tree is out Jesus I my English is
really bad today I tried to put the
trees out a little bit more so that
hopefully they will and try to be
scorched but I'm still not sure if there
are any specific guidelines on distance
between flamethrowers and any near
flammable materials probably are
somewhere but it's something that I
didn't want to really have to worry
about too much in the park here I just
want to tap line throws and finally
there is still some of the work that I
wanted to do to bring the entire park
together and get some detail in areas
when it wasn't before which mostly meant
getting some lights in from every single
pathway and also getting some foliage
and I didn't record all of this there
was still some of the parts that I added
some detailing to that I didn't record
for this episode so you actually have to
see that in the final cinematic video
which is just under a minute long and
then I made as a promotion of the park
or in the final park to which I'm going
to be making in which I'll have a
real-life walkthrough through the park
and show you everything in some more
detail and with some more attention
anyway that is just about it for today
so thank you guys for watching and I
will see you guys next time
[Music]